we're here with Daddy at the recover a
staff designer at Google and a design
sprint mask to run more designs for than
anyone else in the company thank you for
joining us Thank You mere for having me
so when should an entrepreneur think of
design and user experience when building
their product that's a great question
the answer is right away I don't believe
that their successful product that's
separate from being a product or
something that's carefully designed so
as soon as someone's thing about
starting a company it's useful to think
about what is it they want to bring to
the world and that starts the design
process right and when you don't have a
designer or you can't afford its honor
what do you do so we'd like to believe
that anyone can have some of the skills
that the design your haves not the
skills in Photoshop in actually
rendering beautiful marks but the kinds
of questions that the designer asks
we're hoping to cover some of these
today so that you can learn what are the
design skills that can help you quickly
tackle your product and the chief
results with you team even if you're not
a designer you'll hear more about design
Sprint's from Nadia in the next lesson